habitants du Morvan entre Saône-et-Loire
Nièvre et Côte-d'Or Suite à votre
annonce de la fermeture de la maternité
d'Autun cette fermeture provoque un vent
de colère et de révolte chez les équipes
de soignants au combien dévoués mais
aussi chez les élus locaux et la
population devant ce qui est vécu comme
un nouveau déménagement du territoire
cette fermeture suscite l'inquiétude des
femmes enceintes désormais contraintes
de parcourir plus d'une heure voire 1h30
de route pour se rapprocher d'une
maternité alors même qu'une étude
réalisée dans notre région montrait
combien l'augmentation de cette distance
retentit sur la santé périnatale cette
fermeture locale doit préoccuper au
niveau national car monsieur le ministre
vous avez commencé par la justifier
ainsi nous n'arrivons plus à trouver des
professionnels pour assurer la sécurité
est-ce donc là votre seule politique
après avoir fermé une maternité sur
trois en 20 ans votre ministère va-t-il
amplifier cette concentration et fermez
toutes les maternités de niveau 1 du
pays et puis face au tollé provoqué par
votre annonce vous avez renié le mot de
fermeture dans un tweet qui disait
inexact les accouchements sont suspendus
aujourd'hui pour manque de personnel
finalement monsieur le ministre de la
Santé est-ce là votre seul ambition face
aux pénuries médicales que de demander
aux femmes de suspendre les
accouchements et aux malades de
suspendre leur maladie